one of the things that that is amazing
to me when I when I hear about some
people on the right talk about foreign
policy is that the basic idea of
deterrence has gone completely by the
wayside it's as though the only two
policy options and this was sort of the
binary that you used to have Barack
Obama suggesting all the time it was
this binary of appeasement or full scale
War those were the only two possible
outcomes right this what he used to say
about Iran well what do you want you you
want us just go to war with Iran is that
all you want World War I and it was like
no I don't want you to sign a an
appeasement oriented billions of
dollars deal to Iran and I also don't
want you to go War to war with Iran but
the best way to prevent the war with
Iran is to make clear to them that if
they step over this line you're going to
clock them into next week you know that
is what deterrence is I mean if we had
taken the same policy during the Cold
War we would have lost if the policy
during the Cold War had been we either
appease or we go to World War III and so
we appease the Soviet Union would still
be in
existence I want to back up to the
foreign policy stuff because you
mentioned Three Fires there three
different parts of the world Three Fires
do you think this Administration has any
coherent policy as it relates to any of
those uh situations or foreign policy in
general no this Administration policy
what is the what is our policy in
general I don't think anyone knows no no
one knows I mean I think that that Biden
wants to make sounds about America being
a powerful force in the world but he
doesn't want to put his money where his
mouth is so he simultaneously wants to
pull out of Afghanistan but then he
wants to suggest that he is in favor of
projecting American power and that we
are still the global lead leader in
preserving the so-called Global Order
and all the rest of this sort of stuff
and that has led him down all of these
bizarre blind alleys today most recently
the state department putting out sort of
trial balloons about preemptively
declaring a Palestinian state in the
aftermath of this war which is totally
crazy I mean that's literally rewarding
the exact people who perpetrated October
7th and people who side with them and
and giving them a reward for that which
obviously is going to incentivize
tremendous further violence those sorts
of Tri balloons are his policy in the
Middle East is predicated on a couple of
great lies one is the centrality of the
Israeli Palestinian issue to broader
peace in the Middle East same lie that
the Obama Administration was predicated
upon and the second lie is that if you
make nice with Iran if you're
conciliatory toward Iran if you if you
don't slap them down when they when they
get arrogant then probably they'll be
nice to you and of course that didn't
work out well for Barack Obama in any
way shape or form it's not going to work
out well for Joe Biden when it comes to
China Biden's policy has been completely
at odds with itself on the one hand
you've seen them take some economic
measures against China trying to box
China in
on the other hand they've been extremely
conciliatory toward XI not wanting to
offend him to the extent that he makes a
hard move against Taiwan when really
what we should be doing is fortifying
Taiwan against the possibility of that
hard move and building up our military
strength particularly in South China SE
we have to project over there I mean we
have to have Naval power that is capable
of projecting to break a blockade
because in all likelihood China doesn't
actually attack Taiwan if they actually
were to attack Taiwan Taiwan just fries
the microchips and then China's invading
for nothing what they really are
probably going to do is inact a blockade
around Taiwan shut down the Taiwan
Straits and then shut down global
Shipping and basically say if you give
us the microchip so that we have
military parody in terms of Technology
with the United States then we will
release the blockade and then the
question is going to be whether the West
is willing to Brave that blockade if it
comes to like a shooting War over the
blockade is the United States willing to
do that sort of stuff but again now
would be the time to signal to China
that they better not do it now would be
the time to put a couple of aircraft
carriers in the South China Sea for
example and say like if you try this
sort of thing we are willing to fight
you over it not in terms of full scale
World War III War but in terms of
deterrent power again one of the things
that that is amazing to me when I when I
hear about some people on the right talk
about foreign policy is that the basic
idea of deterrence has gone completely
by the wayside it's as though the only
two policy options and this was sort of
the binary that used to have Barack
Obama suggesting all the time it was
this binary of appeasement or fulls
scale War those were the only two
possible outcomes right this what he
used to say about Iran well what do you
want you you want us just go to war with
the Ron is that you want World War I and
it was like no I don't want you to sign
a an appeasement oriented ship billions
of dollars deal to Iran and I also don't
want you to go to war with Iran but the
best way to prevent the war with Iran is
to make clear to them that if they step
over this line you're going to clock
them into next week you know that that
is what deterrence is I mean if we had
taken the same policy during the Cold
War we would have lost if the policy
during the Cold War had been we either
appease or we go to World War III until
we appease the Soviet Union would still
be in existence so this is deterrence is
the fundamental National Security
framework upon which all post World War
II policy
is built because War II essentially was
a failure over deter in the first place
what do you make of the split on the
right related to this because I would
say tucker tends to be in more of the
camp that you're talking about right
there um where to me it's you speak
softly and you carry a big stick I'm I'm
more in agreement with you on deterrence
that's what stops the really bad things
from happening but there clearly is a
lot of energy in that Tucker world let's
say yeah I mean listen the United States
is blessed by God with the greatest
geography of any country on the planet I
mean we are we are largely
self-sufficient economically we have
seas on two sides Canadians and the
North and Mexicans in the south I mean
like we we are we are uniquely blessed
in terms of geography and thank God for
that but that doesn't mean that foreign
policy doesn't impact us I mean if the
if the Freedom of the Seas goes away you
are going to feel that I mean shipping
containers for example are twice as
expensive as they were a few months ago
before the Red Sea was being shut down
everybody was shipping around the the
Cape of Good Hope now that may not sound
like a big deal to people but it is a
big deal to people who are actually
living on the margins in American
society who know have to pay more at the
store I I understand the the impulse to
suggest like why are we involved over
here and you know what I think that's a
great question to ask in in all
circumstances why are we involved and
somebody should then give an explanation
of why we're involved that involves not
just some sort of high fut and moral
language but also involves like hard
real American interests like why are we
involved in this place but to pretend
that America does not have interests
abroad at all or that every every
potential deterrence is an act of
escalation toward war is I think a giant
misread of American foreign policy do
you do you blame some of the that Tucker
America First
Energy on the fact that so many
Republicans helped get us to some of
these stupid Wars over the last three
decades that that was going to be the
result that wasn't going to be much of a
thought out policy it would just be an
Impulse policy sort of as you're
describing I mean that's usually how
politics works right it's actually
mostly a series of impulses by the voter
which is why you'll see the American
voters swivel wildly from I don't want
to be involved in this area of the world
to we need to go in there and wreck
everyone and we swing wildly from one
side to the other right we we what do we
what let's get out of rock we need get
out of a rock like right now we have no
business in Iraq Isis beheads somebody
and we're like okay let's go wreck those
bastards right like the the the swivel
from one to the other is very you I mean
it's it's pretty typical of American
foreign policy actually um and so
there's nothing new about that but that
doesn't mean that that actually makes
for a smart deterrent policy and one of
the big problems with deterrence as a
policy is that it's literally impossible
to see the what would have been if not
right right if you if you successfully
deter a country from going to war then
you don't by necessity you don't see the
war that would have materialized in the
absence of the deterrence and so I
listen I I totally understand the
impulse I certainly understand the the
reaction to the war in Iraq and its
failure I understand the reaction to the
lack of a a functional plan in
Afghanistan like all of that is totally
understandable it's also possible to
swivel too far in in the other direction
in terms of isolationism right the
answer to to full scale interven
wilsonian neoconservatism I don't think
it's isolationism I think that it's
foreign policy realism so for example we
have to look at every conflict and say
is this a conflict where we have an
interest for example did we have an
interest in getting ourselves involved
in Libya I would argue we had no
interest in involving ourselves in Libya
did we have an interest in helping
foment the Arab Spring I would argue
that we had virtually no interest in
many counterveiling interests in
fomenting the Arab Spring for example
there are many foreign policy issues
where you can say like this really is
not our business and frankly we do it
all the time I mean there there's plenty
of major foreign policy conflicts that
are happening right now in Africa for
example where the United States is not
taking a forward- facing position asking
the question as to why we should be
involved in a place is fine good and
useful but when there's an answer there
actually is an answer and to pretend
that there's never an answer or that
everything that happens in the world is
purely because it's blowback because of
American policy in in in a region and
that if we just kind of got our fingers
out of the pie everything would be hunky
dory I think is a looking at the world
through rose-colored glasses if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
n stop screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell